The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
DAVID THORBURN: I want
to continue our discourse
about musicals, especially
as a way of trying
to lead into the two remarkable,
in many ways landmark films
we're going to
juxtapose this evening.
Remember that our plan
here is to juxtapose
one film-- a classic instance,
even a culminating instance
of the studio era
and of the tradition
of the musical in
the studio era--
against another
kind of musical that
appears after the
advent of television,
and after the studio
system has begun
to break apart, and especially
after the fundamental
transformation that the
audience underwent, migrating
from an habitual, a regular,
a weekly relationship
to Hollywood films,
to essentially
a blockbuster relationship,
in which the vast majority
of Americans would attend
the movies only once
or twice a year.
And if you think about
the implications of that,
that fact alone will explain how
profoundly the movie industry
was transformed.
Incidentally, I
should mention to you
that this is still not an idea
that has been fully understood
by what I'll call traditional
film historians, who
are so locked into an idea
that film must resemble
the kind of thing that I
watched when I grew up as a boy,
or as a young girl.
And now that a
tradition of scholarship
has talked about,
that is to say,
those films that never
were shown on television,
or were never made
for television,
it causes a problem.
Because what these
scholars tend to do is they
ignore the social
context within which
the function of the movies
began to be transformed.
Partly there was a
kind of hostility
on the part of many older film
scholars toward the notion
that television might
be a worthy place
to look for a valuable
cinematic narrative.
And it took a long time
before the community
of film scholars--
even a part of it--
was ready to acknowledge
that television was also
an environment in which cinema--
what we might call cinema
audiovisual narrative--
could be look
at, taken seriously,
and so forth.
And of course,
today it's taken for
granted by many
commentators, many of them
no longer even with a cultural
memory of the studio era,
that what goes on
on television--
that shows like Breaking
Bad or The Sopranos
are the supreme forms of
audiovisual entertainment
in our society.
This too is radically
oversimplified.
And I will return
to these questions
a bit later when I talk about
the Westerns, and about film
in the '70s, in two weeks.
I want to continue our discourse
about the musical then, first
by giving you a very brief
prospective drawn from the film
scholar Leo Braudy, whose essay
"The Aesthetics of Connection"
is required reading I think
for this week-- in any case,
for this week or next week.
And he talks in that
essay, among other things,
very richly about the
musical, and about ways
of thinking about the musical.
And I'm borrowing
from an argument he
makes in that remarkable essay.
He makes a distinction
in that essay,
or a series of comparisons
between Astaire and Kelly,
the two great male
leads we associate
with the American film musical.
And he sees them very helpfully
as contrasting figures
illustrating what we might
call contrasting elements,
or contrasting tendencies
within the musical form.
If you think about
Astaire-- and you saw him
in one of his
classic performances
at the end of our last lecture,
in that sequence "Cheek
to Cheek," if you think
about Astaire in this way,
from that sequence
you can get something
of what Braudy had in mind.
He reminds us that Astaire
almost always dances-- and this
is a partial exception in
the film you saw tonight--
only a partial one.
But almost always we
see Astaire dancing
in places that seem
intended for performance.
That is to say we
won't see Astaire
dancing in the middle
of a corn field,
or dancing up the side of
the Empire State Building,
as Frank Sinatra and Gene
Kelly do in a musical-- it's
called On the Town.
And it's one of the
wonderful MGM musicals.
Kelly and Sinatra are
dancing in spaces that
are inappropriate for dance.
But almost all of
Astaire's dances
take place either in
literal performance spaces
or in public
environments that seem
as if they're quasi-stage
or dance environments.
In other words, he
dances in spaces
that we expect for dance.
And he doesn't violate
those spaces in some way.
He often in his films plays
either a professional dancer,
or a professional
performer of some kind.
So when he segues
into his performances,
there's a kind of
natural connection.
He's almost always
very fancily dressed,
as you saw in
tonight's sequence,
sometimes very often
dancing in a tux and tails.
But in any case, in
formal dress of some kind.
So he dances in space is
appropriate for dance,
dressed up in a
kind of formal way,
often playing a professional
dancer or a performer.
But there's an immense grace
and energy in his dancing.
He's one of the
great dancers-- many
would say the greatest
dancer who ever
performed in American movies.
And one way to talk about the
attractions of what he's doing
is we can say that
what he embodies
is the principle of
grace under constraint,
like a great baseball pitcher.
Look.
A lot of people can throw
the ball 97 miles an hour.
But only a very small
number of pitchers
who make a lot of money can
throw a ball 97 miles an hour
and control where it goes.
And we can say that that kind
of athletic power-- a lot
of athletics
involves this, where
you're trying to control
tremendous physical energy.
And the physical energy has to
be constrained in certain ways.
And part of what we admire
about the expression
of that physical energy is
how constrained or graceful
it can become.
There are many
people who have made
analogies between
Astaire's dancing
and what great
basketball players do,
showing tremendous
physical energy,
but also a kind of gracefulness
within the constraints
that are imposed upon them
by the lines on the court,
by the demands of the basket,
by the claims of gravity when
they jump, and so forth.
And I make allusion to
these non-dance analogies,
because so many people
seem to respond more fully
to those than to dance itself,
even though those of you who
have danced, or are dancers,
or know serious dancers,
will understand that
dancers themselves
are much greater athletes
than most athletes,
and that there is a profound
form of athleticism,
of physical energy, grace,
and physical control involved
in dance.
And we see that in
Astaire's performances.
It's as if he stands for a
form of grace under constraint,
of strength and power
constrained but not undermined
by the rules and boundaries
within which it must operate.
It's a form of classical art.
And what we can say is that
Kelly stands for classicism.
I'm sorry.
Astaire stands for
classicism, and Gene Kelly,
who is a kind of opposite
in this way in his dances,
stands for the romantic.
The classic and the romantic
tendencies or energies.
I'm oversimplifying
here, as Braudy does.
But again, it's a useful and
illuminating simplification.
Because we see
Kelly for example,
mostly he doesn't play
professional performers,
or professional dancers.
He almost always wears
ordinary casual clothing--
open shirts, jeans.
And this casualness
of appearance
is matched by the fact that
the dances he engages in often
take place in spaces that are
not appropriate for dance,
or almost hostile to dance.
And one of the
deepest principles
of Kelly's performances--
of Kelly's dances--
in a certain sense is this
contest between his exuberance
and energy, and the
constraints that surround him.
But unlike Astaire, he does
not reveal the power and grace
of his dance by
acknowledging the constraints
and living within them.
The energy of his
dance expresses itself
in the moments when he over-goes
boundaries, when he violates
borders of various kinds.
And there are numerous examples
of this in Singin' in the Rain.
I'll mention some of
them in a little while.
So the contrast between
Kelly and Astaire
in this way-- and
look, in both cases
I've simplified, because
they also resemble each other
in certain ways.
But these tendencies
distill quality.
This argument distills
qualities in them
that clarify certain
energies or tensions that
can be said to be
characteristic,
not only of two dance styles
and the kinds of movies
these two stars are in, but
also in the musical genre
as a whole.
I'd like to say a
couple of things
about each of the
two films we're
going to see tonight,
by way of framing
some of the most important
issues for you to think about.
And these are very
rich, complex texts.
And 20 minutes of conversation,
no matter how pointed,
can never do full
justice to them.
I don't intend to do
full justice to them.
But I want to suggest
some ways for you
to think about aspects of these
films as you're viewing them.
And my hope and expectation
is that these perspectives
will energize and
enliven the film for you,
and cue you in to
aspects of the film
that you might otherwise
not see as deeply,
or might not occur to you
until you reflected on the film
after the case.
One way to think about
Singin' in the Rain,
then-- our example of
a Hollywood musical,
or a culminating instance
of a Hollywood musical--
is to recognize that it belongs
to a subcategory of musicals--
to several subcategories
of musicals, one of which
I've already mentioned--
the putting on the show,
the backstage story.
But here the backstage
story is the story
of a movie, instead of a play.
But it's the same
basic situation.
But it is also sometimes
called a song catalog
movie, because there's
so many songs in it.
And that's kind of
a kind of catalog,
or an encyclopedic object.
An encyclopedia of film,
of music, and of song.
And this is almost literally
true of Singin' in the Rain.
Arthur Freed, the
executive producer
of so many major films--
over 40 MGM musicals
between something
like 1939-- what
was the great musical in 1939?
The Wizard of Oz-- the first
musical that is thought
to be a musical in color.
And think how organically
The Wizard of Oz uses color.
Arthur Freed was the executive
producer of that film.
From that point until
sometime in the 1960s,
he was the executive
producer or the supervisor
of something like
40-plus MGM musicals,
of which Singin' in the
Rain is a classic instance.
And so Freed had
worked as a lyricist.
Arthur Freed had worked
as a lyricist at MGM
with Nacio Herb Brown--
the songwriter--
many years earlier.
And most of the songs in
Singin' in the Rain, 1952,
had been introduced in
MGM musicals from 1929 on.
So in a literal sense,
the film is a kind
of encyclopedia of older songs.
And especially two key songs
in the film-- "Broadway Melody"
and "You Were Meant for
Me," were both featured
in that early and
signature musical,
founding musical that I
mentioned this afternoon,
The Broadway Melody of 1929.
So part of the pleasure
for older members
of the audience
in 1952 would have
been to hear and
see these numbers
in the new, souped-up
arrangements that
were created for this film, and
in such artful performances.
There's one song in the film
that my colleague Martin
Marks-- M-A-R-K-S-- he
sometimes teaches this course
in the spring.
He's a professor of music.
And he sometimes-- and
I encourage all of you
to consider taking it--
teaches an advanced course
in the American musical.
It's a wonderfully
interesting course.
And he knows more
about the musical,
I think, than almost
any living human being.
And I'm stealing from
some of his teaching notes
here when I say this.
One song that Marty
Marks loves to talk about
is a minor song in the film.
And I'm mentioning it because
you might miss it otherwise.
It's called "Would You?"
And it's a song that chose
the process of dubbing.
And it's a song that actually
has a kind of a plot,
and historical function
within the film.
It comes near the
end of the film.
And when it was
sung in this moment,
it was already old-fashioned
in its original day,
when it was first
written and sung.
And by 1952 it's
much more outmoded,
Professor Marks tells us.
Although it's a simple
and graceful waltz,
it uses an antiquated
diction, for example.
And there are other
signals-- even the fact
that it's a waltz--
that show it to be
kind of old-fashioned in a way.
But in Singin' in the Rain,
this old-fashioned song
is used to telescope
the process of recording
for films shot-by-shot.
Watch how it happens.
It's a very exciting moment.
And so what happens then is
that the old-fashioned song
becomes the cornerstone
of the new technology
of sound recording.
Watch how it
happens in the film.
And what this calls
our attention to
is something I've
talked about earlier,
and will return to in a moment--
the idea that in the most
remarkable works of art we
are surely aware of the fact
that we're in the
presence of what
the literary critics
and the art critics
sometimes call organic form,
in which the form of the text
contributes to its meaning,
in which form and content are
married, can't
really be separated.
That the formal
behavior of the text
enacts or embodies or
articulates or dramatizes
what the film is about,
what the text means.
I'll come back to this point
in a minute with even more
dramatic examples, I hope.
And an added point
about this "Would You?"
song, just this one
sort of minor sequence--
I'm mentioning this
partly to show you
how deeply you
could actually dig
into particular sequences and
particular songs in the film,
and find meaning, relevance,
and complexity there.
When Debbie Reynolds,
who sings the song,
looks point blank at Gene
Kelly as she sings it,
she drives home the question of
whether he'll be brave enough
to love her, So it
even implicates itself
in the love story that's
at the heart of the film.
Her singing voice, we might
note ironically and comically,
in this scene is actually
dubbed for this song.
And you'll understand
if you haven't
seen the film why that's a
comic and ironic commentary.
She had the wrong kind of voice.
It was too flat and nasal for
this operetta-like number.
So they dubbed her voice.
So there's a double
irony here, because she's
playing a dubber when
she's singing the song.
And you might compare the
voice in "Good Morning,"
another number in the film,
where Debbie Reynolds is really
singing.
And you can see the difference
between the two voices.
So the implicit
point that I made
in talking about
this one number,
the "Would You?"
song number, it has
to do with what we might
call a central element
or feature of
Singin' in the Rain,
its profound self-consciousness,
the profound way in which it
shows itself to be aware of
itself-- to be aware of itself
as a movie, to be
aware of itself
as a bearer of
traditions of singing,
of dancing, and performance.
And so it isn't
simply an encyclopedia
of musical history.
It's almost an encyclopedia
of almost all forms
of performance.
I don't want to go too far.
But there's many, many
forms of performance
are incorporated in the film's
grasp, in the film's embrace.
All right?
One way we can think of it as
an encyclopedic recapitulation
of the history of musicals,
and of films in general.
As you'll notice when you
look at the film, Singin'
in the Rain begins by being
about the problem of changing
a silent film into a sound film,
because the silent has been
made just at that cusp moment
when the transition to sound
is occurring.
And the film in
that sense is also
a wonderful sort of historical
reprise for our course,
even though it wasn't made
for that purpose, alas.
So in the film,
then, we also get
an allusion to and
a representation
of silent movies.
But not just some generic
idea of silent movies--
a very particular kind of
swashbuckler adventure film
is dramatized there.
But then later, in a scene
I mentioned earlier today,
in the audition scene,
the beautiful girls
sequence in Singin' in the
Rain where a megaphone suddenly
turns into a circle of dancers,
alluding to the Busby Berkeley
tradition, we have a
very specific reference
to another kind
of movie musical.
So, juxtaposed
against each other
are two different
kinds of movies,
And I've only mentioned
a couple of examples.
As you watch the film,
you'll see dozens and dozens
of instances in which the
film capaciously reaches back
to older forms of performance,
and tries to incorporate them
in some sense into
its own structure,
into its own energies.
And there are many older
performance forms in the film.
There are forms of slapstick,
and Keaton-like comedy--
especially in Donald O'Connor's
wonderful dance and song
sequence "Make 'em Laugh."
There are allusions
and references
and dramatized scenes
from vaudeville,
from jazz, from
what we might call
forms of love melodrama, all
the way through the film.
And I haven't really
cataloged even remotely
all the kinds of performance
spaces and performance types
that the film
incorporates and utilizes
in the course of its length.
Nor have I even begun to list
the number of musical styles--
particular songs and particular
dance styles-- that are also
incorporated into the film.
But I've said enough to suggest
that Singin' in the Rain
has what might be
called a structural
or a formal exuberance,
a kind of excitement,
as if every time
it turns it wants
to make an allusion to
another kind of text,
as if it feels itself in some
sense with a kind of excitement
and exuberant energy constantly
in touch with its ancestry,
and within ancestry that it
tries to define very generously
and broadly.
And so what we're
saying is that formally,
structurally, the
film is expressing
a special kind of intellectual
energy, excitement, exuberance.
And of course what's interesting
and fundamental about that
is that those energies
are also replicated,
centrally reenacted in
the actual dance sequences
that we see in the film.
It's a profoundly rich example
of what I called a moment ago
organic form.
The structure or the
shape of the film
contributes to
our sense not only
that it has a kind of
encyclopedic, self-reflexive
interest in its own
history, and that it's
recapitulating its own
history for us as it proceeds.
We also have a deep sense of
the extent to which the film
understands that many of the
older forms it dramatizes
are now simply being archived,
as if the film understands
itself not only as a
dramatic entertainment,
but also as a kind
of history book,
or a kind of encyclopedia--
literally a kind
of archive of all the forms of
performance and song and dance
that lie behind the
making of such a film.
And of course that this
formal exuberance, as I said,
is repeated again and again in
an actualized and concrete way
in the story, in
the plot, every time
the characters start
singing or dancing.
And as you'll see,
there's a particular kind
of exuberance and energy
in many of the dances.
Key themes.
Well I've already implicitly
been talking about some
of the themes.
But let me mention just
two that seem to me
especially significant.
One I've mentioned much earlier.
And I simply want
to remind you again
that this tension between
what might be called high art,
and the pretentious expectations
of a cultural establishment,
are set up for parody
and mockery in this film
repeatedly.
The film is on the side of
the popular and the energetic,
and the unpretentious.
And one can feel that
tension again and again
in many, many of the sequences
in the movie in the film.
Let me give you just
two obvious examples.
In the very opening
sequence of the film,
one of the classic moments in
the history of American movies
replayed again and again
in compilation anthologies
of great moments in Hollywood,
great moments of Hollywood
film, is the
introduction to the film.
And the introduction
to Singin' in the Rain
recreates an
historical actuality
that I need to remind
today's audiences of.
Shows you how old
this course is.
Because when I first began
to teach this course,
these practices
were still going on,
and the students
still understood,
and in fact had their own
experience of exhibition
movies, and of going to
theaters that were very lavish
and, in many ways,
even pretentious.
And what they were
especially aware of
is something I
have to remind you
of now, which is that
very often Hollywood
had a strategy of rolling
out its great blockbuster,
what it hoped would be
great blockbuster films,
with very elaborate
inaugural events.
The debut of a film was
often a major event.
And it would be
covered by newspapers.
And many Hollywood stars
would come and attend.
And they would turn the
event into a publicity event
partly in order to get publicity
for the release of the film.
And Singin' in the Rain
opens with such a moment,
in which a film is opening.
And it dramatizes the
comic hypocrisies that
attend such publicity gestures.
And as the film opens
then, we see a sequence
in which the stars of the film
we're about to see, Gene Kelly,
is interviewed.
The star of the film is
interviewed by a reporter.
And he then tells sort of
the story of his career.
But the story that he
tells is fake-- is a lie.
It's very pretentious.
Oh, we went to the
best conservatories.
We were trained by classical
musicians and classical
actors-- "ac-TORS."
And he acts very pretentious.
But that's what he says.
But what we see,
what is shown to us
is the actual history of how
Don Lockwood and his partner,
his sidekick, played by the
brilliant performer Donald
O'Connor, really
got their start.
And so while he
says, we were trained
in the best
conservatories, what we
see are Donald O'Connor
and Gene Kelly dancing
in a burlesque show.
And so that there's this very
obvious, even in some ways
crude mockery or laughter at
the hypocrisies of Hollywood.
And part of what's
being celebrated
there is the exuberance and
energy, of unsanctioned forms
of performance, like
the dances that people
do in burlesque shows, as
against what you do when you go
to the museum, or when
you come to the university
and have your professor
declaim ancient Greek to you
in syllables you have
no understanding of.
So there's one example of
how that theme plays out.
But you can find it
in dozens and dozens
of other places in the film.
And I hope you'll
watch for such moments.
So I won't give you
my second example.
I'm running out of time.
Let me turn to the
next large theme
I want you to be aware of.
I call it the theme
of outer versus inner.
It's really a variation
on or an extension
of the theme of high versus
popular art, in the sense
that it's also about the
difference between a kind
of pretentious and constraining
and old-fashioned view
of things, and a
more spontaneous
and we might even say
a more spontaneous
and popular or democratic
view of things.
And the term I give
it is the difference
between outer and inner, or the
difference between appearance
and reality.
And in fact the example
I just gave you,
in which we have Don Lockwood
telling the reporter that he
was educated in the
best conservatories
while we see that he's
dancing in a burlesque show,
is an example of that
kind of thing as well.
But there are many other
very dramatic examples.
And I want to mention
one of them now.
When the Debbie Reynolds
character-- the love interest
of our protagonist-- first meets
the Don Lockwood character--
the character played
by Gene Kelly--
she pretends not to recognize
him, even though he's
a famous movie star.
And she says, oh, she spends
her time watching Shakespeare,
but she doesn't spend much
time watching the movies.
And Don Lockwood is kind
of offended by this.
It later turns out-- not
even that much later--
that of course the
Debbie Reynolds character
herself is deeply immersed
in the popular culture.
Right after she makes this
comment to Don Lockwood,
or a few minutes
after that, we find
her jumping out of the cake
as a dancer at a party.
And then as more
information emerges later,
we come to recognize, of course,
that she knows a great deal
about Don Lockwood.
She's always been a
tremendous fan of the movies.
But she's been covering it up.
And again and again
in the film we
see this kind of tension
playing itself out,
this tension between a
kind of outer facade.
And the notion is that what
is shown on the outside,
the exterior of things is often
fake, a mere cover for what
is authentic and within,
And you can understand
this in a number of ways.
One of the ways it
plays out in the movie
is the question
of the person who
is in front of the
audience and singing,
but it's not really her voice.
It's the voice of
Debbie Reynolds,
who's behind the curtain.
And so that again, this
theme of the artificial
versus the authentic, or
the outer versus the inner,
plays itself out in many,
many ways in the film.
That's part of what makes
the film so coherent, so
dramatically effective
and energetic.
And so another way of
thinking about this sequence,
this idea of the outer person
versus the inner, authentic
person; the outer appearance,
the illusion that film makes,
but what really goes
on behind the scenes.
And as you'll discover,
Singin' in the Rain
constantly takes us
behind the scenes
to show us how the illusion
of movies is put together.
And that's a part
of this same theme.
So one of the things I'm trying
to call your attention to again
is the way in which the
central ideas of the film
permeate both its
form and its content
in ways that make it very
difficult to separate.
Finally, one last
fundamental issue
connected to what I've
been saying before,
the way the film
meditates on or dramatizes
an idea about the place of
song and dance in human life.
You will have
noticed, of course,
that I myself
feel-- and if you've
seen any of the
performances in this film,
you'll know yourselves-- that a
principle of energy, vitality,
playfulness, exuberance
is almost always
present in the dances
in Singin' in the Rain.
Song and dance is seen
in Singin' in the Rain
as a morally and psychologically
revolutionary experience,
I think.
And I use the word "revolution"
in a dangerous way.
I don't mean a politically
revolutionary way,
but I mean in a morally, a
psychologically revolutionary
way.
And so what's going
on in some sense
is the sense that constraint
and convention are constantly
threatened by the exuberance,
spontaneity, energy,
excitement, vitality
of the dance.
And this expresses itself in
all kinds of ways in the film.
Let me just mention a couple
to call your attention to.
You'll discover many,
many other examples.
One is the wonderful sequence,
the Moses supposes sequence.
This is a sequence in which Don
Lockwood and his partner Donald
O'Connor have to be
trained, because they're
making the transition to sound.
And the studio calls
in an elocution expert,
who's dressed up like a very
pretentious old-line professor.
And he's going to teach them how
to pronounce things correctly.
So he comes in,
and he says, I want
you to repeat after me-- "Moses
supposes his toses are roses.
But Moses supposes erroneously."
He's also ugly.
His teeth are disgusting.
So you're already
offended by the guy
before Don and his
comrade begin to respond.
And also, of course, what's
ridiculous about this?
It's meaningless talk.
He's so interested in making
them pronounce the "O"
vowel properly that he
creates meaningless sentences.
But their meaninglessness amuses
Don Lockwood and his partner.
And essentially what they do
is they take the Moses supposes
lines, and they begin to
sort of make fun of them.
And they begin to make
fun of their interlocutor,
their teacher.
They end up taking a garbage
can and emptying it out
just has paper in it--
putting it on his head.
They end up dancing
in a ridiculous way.
So they end up dancing on top of
desks, or up the side of walls.
Again, what are they doing?
Their dances are violating
the normal spaces
in which we expect people to
be walking or standing upright.
The very way in which the dance
violates normal boundaries
creates this sense of
exuberance and of freedom.
So what they're doing
is they're rebelling
against the pretentiousness,
the constraints of this kind
of high-culture expectation.
And the song and dance in
the Moses supposes sequence
create a kind of
exuberant chaos in which
they dance on the tables and
make fun of the very elements
that they're supposed
to be learning.
The "Good Morning"
sequence-- one
of the great sequences in the
history of movies, I think--
shows the same thing.
It takes place at breakfast
in an ordinary domestic space,
which is transfigured
or transformed,
including the
props, in something
we might imagine Chaplin
doing such imaginative things,
in which the ordinary props
of the kitchen become partners
in the dance, become elements
in the dance-- what we feel
is the imaginative power
of love and of performance
transforming an ordinary space.
And we can see this
principle operating
with an even greater
force in the title
sequence of the film-- probably
the most famous sequence
of dance in the history
of Hollywood, the Singin'
in the Rain sequence itself.
We see the rain itself.
What a funny place
to be dancing,
There's a contradiction.
But your exuberance, your
energy, your sense of love
is so great that even
rain doesn't matter.
And watch what happens.
He has an umbrella, but he
doesn't use the umbrella
to protect him from the rain,
violating our expectation.
There's one wonderful
moment in the film where
he hands the umbrella in
the midst of pouring rain
to someone else, to a
pedestrian who goes by,
There's a moment when
he's dancing in the rain.
He puts the umbrella down.
The rain's coming.
But he doesn't have enough
rain pouring on him.
He steps under a downspout to
have even more rain come down
on him.
And when we experience
this, one of the reasons
we experience this as joyful,
and as assertive, and as
individualizing, is
the sense we have
that these are exactly not
things that people normally do.
He's over-going or violating
certain conventions
or literal boundaries.
And there's one moment in
the dance, very dramatic.
And I know this
incidentally, not
because I've
discovered it myself,
but because 20 years ago or
15 years ago in this course
a student who later went
on to work in Hollywood--
and he still works there.
He's a sound genius.
He was an MIT engineer
who loved this course,
and was a musician as well.
He wrote a paper for
me about that sequence.
And he showed me this.
And I'm sure that some
smart critics also saw it,
but I learned this
from an MIT student
in this course
about 15 years ago.
He analyzed the dance
sequence very closely.
And one of the
things he showed was
that the decisive
moment in the dance
occurs-- or a decisive
occurs-- when the Kelly
character suddenly-- he's
dancing on the
sidewalk-- jumps off
the sidewalk across the
curb into the street.
And psychologically it has a
tremendously profound effect,
because you don't
walk in the street,
much less dance in the street.
The street is for cars.
But that violation
of the boundary
expresses the sense
of exuberance,
of freedom that is the
essential meaning of what
these dances represent.
So energy, spontaneous feeling,
performing and over-going
limits is one of
the things that's
being expressed in the
exuberance of the film's
formal structure, in its
encyclopedic reaching out
to other forms which
it was to incorporate
into itself, and in its
particular dance and song
sequences.
And this energy,
this celebration
of transformative energy, of
the over-going of boundaries,
strikes me as
particularly American,
as a uniquely
interesting expression
of what people have
sometimes called
American optimism, and even
of the democratic spirit,
of the openness that we
associate with our ideals--
not the reality, but our
ideals-- of democratic society.
What these dances
and songs tell us
then about the place of
dance and song in our lives,
the idea that you would begin
to dance in a space unused
to dance, hostile to dance,
transforms the space.
So what this film then
says about these things is
that our speech can be nudged
into song, our way of walking
can be edged into a dance,
and that the ordinary objects
in our domestic
and public spaces
can become props in
an improvised ballet.
When we turn to
Cabaret, we're looking
at a very different
kind of object.
And it's important to recognize
what I mentioned earlier,
and I will develop more fully
in a couple of weeks, the fact
that now we have gone
almost beyond genre.
There are people
who would argue--
and there are purists,
scholars of the musical film
who want to argue that,
well, Cabaret really
isn't a musical for
a variety of reasons.
It seems to me a very strange
and unhelpful argument.
But I think if you
watch the film closely,
you'll understand why
people who are partisans
of the great Hollywood musical
tradition, or even the older
operatic tradition
represented by value directors
like Rouben Mamoulian would
have problems fitting Cabaret
into the category of musical.
I think it's a
misunderstanding of how
we should think about musicals.
But for the moment, let me just
encourage you to watch the film
and think about
how different it is
from traditional musicals--
and especially its tone,
its moral perspective.
But also it's in its structure.
Think about that,
and you'll understand
more fully why it's easy to see
that this film would be very
unlikely to have been
made in the Hollywood era,
that it required the
kind of freedom that
came to film after film
was no longer constrained
by the necessity to speak
in a consensus voice.
And as I said,
these are matters I
will try to clarify and
conclude in two weeks
when I return to this question,
when we talk about film
in the '70s, and the
great '70s Western--
almost contemporary with
Cabaret-- Robert Altman's
McCabe and Mrs. Miller.
I had hoped to say a number of
things about Fosse's career,
but I don't have time.
And I'm just going to
encourage you-- look him up.
He's a very, very
remarkable figure.
I call him "The Inheritor"
because he was both a Broadway
director and
choreographer and a dancer
both on Broadway and in films.
And he performed and directed
He was first a
choreographer in films
before he became a director.
And in this career as a
performer and choreographer,
he linked up with almost
all the other great names
of the American musical
stage-- both the Broadway stage
and the Hollywood tradition.
And in that sense, we
can say that Bob Fosse
is the inheritor of
the great tradition
of the American musical.
And I wish I could go
into detail about this
and show you how
many affiliations
and specific connections he
has with the great figures
of the classical age
of American movies,
and especially the classical
age of the American musical.
But suffice it to say that it's
a very rich set of connections.
And his career is a
very remarkable career,
a very honored career.
Let me mention one fact
about his career, perhaps
the most remarkable
one, easy to remember.
Tells you something
about his diversity
as a director, his
gifts, his ambition.
In 1973, Bob Fosse I think
became the only man in history
to win an Oscar, a Tony, and
an Emmy-- an Oscar for Cabaret
as best director, and a Tony
for-- or maybe he either he
won as best director
or the play that he
directed on Broadway-- Pippin
won as best play on Broadway.
And he also won a
television Emmy for a show
starring Liza Minnelli,
the star in Cabaret,
called Liza with a
'Z.' So And I think
he's the only man in history
for whom those three awards came
in the same year for
three different texts.
He directed one, two,
three, four, five films,
of which Cabaret was the second.
The last four are all very
remarkable and interesting
texts.
I won't talk about
them here, except
to encourage you to look
him up and think about them.
The theme of performance and
the idea of the characters
who are themselves
performers are always
at the center of his films.
Not all of his
films involve dance.
He made a film about
the life of Lenny Bruce
called Lenny starring
Dustin Hoffman,
for example, that doesn't
have musical numbers in it.
But it has many
performance numbers in it.
And it's a very rich,
complex, sophisticated film.
So an interesting and
profoundly serious director.
I wish I could say
more about his career.
I want to say a word about
the context of Cabaret,
so you'll understand that aspect
of the film more fully, too.
It's set in Weimar Germany,
that curious time in the 1920s
during the rise of Nazism,
but long before Hitler
has come to power,
in which the Weimar
Republic, a vulnerable
and unstable democracy,
but a democracy in
which an enormous amount
of artistic and literary
experimentation was taking
place.
It's the period of
German expressionism.
It's the period of the
great German silent films
that we talked about earlier.
And so our film Cabaret
is set in that era,
and in that driven
era, in that divided
era in which the rise of Nazism
was coupled with or joined to
and connected to the fact
that German society was
under immense
constraints, because it
had lost the first World War.
Conditions under which they
had been forced to surrender
were very onerous.
There was very high
levels of unemployment.
It was a schizophrenically
divided society,
a society of great
artistic energies,
but of great political
divisions and
difficulties, and
nightmare possibilities
that were lurking in
many of its practices.
And there's a link-- or
at least a partial link--
between the instability
and the excitement,
but also the dividedness
of Weimar Germany,
and the actual condition of
the United States in the era
when the movie came
out, Because this
is the period at
the end of the '60s,
after the late '60s
and early '70s,
probably the most divided
time in American history
after the Second World War
before our current moment.
And in fact, the divisions
then were more legitimate.
By more legitimate, I mean
they had a more sensible cause.
There were terrible
wars going on.
There were better reasons
for the partisanship that
occurred in the late
'60s and early '70s
than there are for the weird
partisanship we're suffering
in the United States today.
And in any case, there
was a much greater sense
in the late '60s and
early '70s that the fabric
of American society was under
attack, that it was imperfect,
not only because the
Vietnam War had so
divided the country
against itself, but because
of other matters as well,
including the increasing
militancy of the
civil rights movement,
which had gone from a sort
of a Martin Luther King type
commitment to nonviolent
protest into much more
disturbing and sometimes
violent confrontations
with authorities, and with some
theorists and speakers actually
calling for violence.
And this racial tension
was then coupled
by another kind of political
tension coming from the people,
from the young men and
women-- who were mostly
young men and women-- who were
opposed to the Vietnam War.
So it was a very driven
and disturbed time.
There were then parallels
between the instability
and the disturbance
of the Weimar period
and the period in which
the film appeared.
And the original
audiences, I think,
would have been highly
aware of this connection,
would have seen that although
the film was set in the past,
it spoke to the contemporary
moment in a very powerful way.
I want also remind
you that there
are certain aspects of
the style of Cabaret
that are worth keeping in mind.
And one way to
think about this is
to recognize that both mis en
scene style and montage style
are embodied in the film,
and are carried to extremes
in certain moments of the film.
That is to say, in many of
the performance sequences
in the film, the camera behaves
in an unbelievably frenetic and
frantic way-- changes your
eye angle, jumps around a lot,
disorients you sometimes--
almost disorients you
in the style of a Hitchcock.
And yet in other sequences
in the film, especially
those outside the cabaret that
take place in ordinary life,
not in a performance space,
the camera and the editing
slow down and become more like
a kind of mise en scene style.
And the combination of
the two is especially
rich and interesting.
You might want to watch for
the way these rhythms alter
your sense of what's
happening in the film,
the way the film slows down,
and speeds up at certain point.
And I mean this literally in
terms of the number of images
that go by quickly, but
also in terms of the way
the physical bodies
of the performers
move across the screen.
And of course the way
in which the camera
itself behaves,
whether it's jittery,
oriented toward
constant movement;
or whether it's more
stable and gives you
a chance to look
at the environment
this scene is set in.
One way I could give you a sense
of the richness of the film
is to remind you that there's a
kind of texture or multiplicity
in Cabaret in almost every
moment, that if you watch
for it, and you're
attentive to it,
you will always be rewarded.
Let me just give you
two very quick examples
of what I mean by this.
Remember I suggested to you that
this principle of multiplicity
is one of the principles
we turn to if we want
to recognize a work of art.
The difference
between a work of art
and an entertainment in my
terms is that a work of art
is just more intelligent.
That is to say, it makes more
complex use of its materials.
So that in a entertainment,
a particular event or gesture
may have only one function.
But in a work of art, you
will have multiple functions.
It will perform several
jobs simultaneously.
I'll give you two
examples of this.
Think about what takes place
on the periphery of what
you're watching, and you'll
begin to get some sense of one
way in which the texture of this
film brings the material alive.
There's one moment I think
fairly early in the film.
It's a street scene.
We're not paying much
attention to what's going on.
We see, I think, the protagonist
walking in the street.
And around on the
periphery-- certainly not
in the center of
the frame, nothing
that is commented on
by the characters--
a cripple slides by on one
of those wheeled platforms
that people without legs
sometimes used in major cities
before-- maybe
they still happen.
But they were very common in the
first half of the 20th century.
And we see this guy.
Obviously he's a wounded
veteran, and he's an amputee.
And he pushes himself
along on this cart.
And we just see him go by.
But what's
interesting about that
is that this cripple
on the platform
has a little flag
on his platform.
Guess what kind of a flag it is?
It's a Nazi flag.
And this is early in the
film, before the Nazis
have become a powerful force.
The rise of Nazism is in
the background of film,
as you will see.
The Nazis moved
from the periphery
to the center of the frame
before the film is over.
And that's the fundamental
historical motion of the film.
But all of that's taking
place in the background.
The foreground are the
central characters,
and the comic and innocent--
and ultimately not so comic,
disturbing love affairs
and difficulties
that they encounter
in this environment.
They're too naive or
innocent to understand
the historical forces
that are surrounding them.
So that example of the
Nazi flag and this crippled
figure-- because the
crippled figure is in fact
an allusion to the
onerous demands that
were put upon Germany by
France and the other allies
at the end of the war.
And he's crippled.
So the assumption is he's
probably a war veteran.
I don't remember
if he's actually
wearing a uniform, which
would confirm this.
And it would be
helpful if he were.
But I don't remember.
Watch for it, and you'll see.
But in any case,
he refers to that.
Anyone attentive to
the firm can recognize
that the historical
texture of the film
is carried by such moments.
There's another such
moment, also so minor
that you might not notice it.
The foreground is
the love affair,
or not yet a love affair, but
the acquaintance, the deepening
friendship between
the two protagonists--
Sally Bowles and her boyfriend.
And they go out for
a walk in Berlin.
And Sally pretends that she's
this immensely sophisticated
woman.
Turns out that she's fooling
herself and fooling us.
She's not at all,
even though she
pretends to a great
kind of sophistication.
And she sings dirty
songs in a cabaret,
and she performs
in a cabaret where
they make jokes
about everything,
including all forms
of sexual perversion.
Nonetheless, she's an innocent.
She has no way of recognizing
the depth and complexity
of the moral evil and
moral terror that's
building around her.
And she's not alone in this.
Most of the other characters
in the foreground of the film
perform this same naive
ballet, although Sally Bowles
is the most powerful
instance of it.
It is certainly Liza
Minnelli's greatest role.
Certainly the role that
she'll be remembered
for long after she's dead.
Long after we're
all in the ground,
Liza Minnelli's
performance in this film
will still be treasured
and savored, I think.
So another instance
of the multiplicity.
When we find the two characters
are walking in the street,
and Sally says, oh, I want
to show you something I do.
And she pulls this guy along.
She leans up against the side
of an elevated train stanchion.
And she waits until
the train comes by.
And as the train
comes by, she screams.
And she says, see?
Whenever you wait for the noise,
nobody will hear you scream.
And she's just expressing
her exuberance.
She's showing him
how she commands
this space, how she knows
how to use this urban space.
But there's an irony
she's unaware of.
When she leans up against the
wall behind her, what we see
are political posters.
And the political posters
behind her are defaced.
They're both Nazi and
communist posters.
And the communists
and the Nazis are
defacing one another's posters.
And what is implicit then
again in the background
against the foreground of these
two relatively naive characters
carrying on is the
historical reality
that's building behind them.
Another example of what I
mean by the multiplicity,
the texture of this film.
Next to finally, the
musical numbers--
penultimately the
musical numbers.
Another kind of integration
is going on in this film,
when we talk about the
integrated musical as Arthur
Freed and his comrades during
the studio era articulated
this idea.
We're not talking about
the form of integration
that we see in Cabaret.
And this in fact is
one of the reasons
that some people argue that
Cabaret is not a musical.
Because with one exception,
none of the musical performances
in Cabaret take place out of
a performance environment.
They all take place
in the cabaret.
The film is about a
cabaret performer,
and we see many
performances in the cabaret.
Now when we watch
those performances,
we see them from angles
that no one in the audience
could ever see, because Fosse
is a genius with the camera,
and creates visual
effects drawing
on the tradition of
the Hollywood musical
that could never be
replicated in a theater.
Nonetheless, the
performances themselves
are theatrical performances.
They all are real performances.
And when we see the characters
behaving like real characters,
they don't suddenly burst
into song and dance.
Because there's something
theoretically so implausible
about that, that Cabaret
refuses that convention.
It refuses to embrace
that basic convention
of the American musical,
which is that one
way that people express their
exuberance-- I love you.
I love you.
Now let me sing a
song telling you
how much I love you-- whereas
in real life we don't do that.
Now I don't think that this
convention is a convention that
undermines the musical.
It's a convention, or
a rule, or a habit,
a protocol you need to
embrace in order to experience
these films appropriately.
And it's no more
implausible in one sense
than the implausibility
of opera singers
bursting into song at
moments of great passion.
The convention requires it.
It's as if we're in a form
of artistic experience
in which art is crystallizing
experience for us.
So I don't mean to undermine
this convention at all,
or cast doubt on it.
But Cabaret refuses
that convention--
with one exception.
And I'm calling attention
to that exception.
I'm not going to
tell you what it is,
but I want you to watch for it.
There's one moment in the
film when there is a song sung
outside by ordinary people.
It happens spontaneously.
It may be the most morally
and historically frightening
moment in the whole of the film.
And it's completely
believable, totally
plausible that it would happen.
But that's the only moment
in the film when there's
any singing that doesn't take
place inside a space intended
for singing and dancing.
So one of the interesting
things about Cabaret
is that there is a kind of true
integration of song and dance,
because none of that
happens except in spaces
where it's appropriate--
realistically appropriate.
And so you might watch for that.
And the complexity
that this decision
on the part of Bob
Fosse and the people
making the film, the
impact of that decision
on your understanding
of the movie as a whole.
Finally, the central
themes of the film.
I've already talked about them.
The theme of innocence-- the
way the central characters
in the film are too
innocent to understand
the historical forces around
them, underestimate them.
This isn't just true
of the central figures.
It's true of the
secondary characters
as well, some of whom even more
poignantly embody this theme.
And then the theme of history.
What history is.
How the force of history can
overwhelm individual desires,
individual hopes, love itself.
And of course, also
the limits of satire.
The cabaret is a space of
satire, a space of mockery,
a space of exuberant
intellectual distance
and disdain.
Much of the energy
of the cabaret
comes from an impulse of
parity, mockery, satire.
And in the very
beginning of the film,
there's actually a moment
where you can see the Joel Grey
character, who plays this
ominous, strange figure
of the emcee, the
interlocutor, in the cabaret.
He sort of is the
master of ceremonies.
And there's one moment
early in the film when
he, in a rather disgusting
scene in which they replicate
a scene of mud wrestling.
And he's emceeing it.
And he reaches down, and
he picks up a piece of mud.
And he rubs it on his upper lip.
And he makes himself
look like Hitler.
And he's mocking Hitler in that.
Well if you compare
that early moment
in which Hitler and Nazism
are objects of mockery,
there's also an
early scene in which
we see a Nazi being pulled out
of the audience of the cabaret
and pushed outside,
kicked out of the cabaret,
because Nazis are thought
to be unacceptable.
They're thought
to be vulgarians.
This is early in the film.
By the time the film is
over, by the time you
come to the very
end of the film,
one of the very final
images of the film
shows us the audience
of the cabaret filled
with Nazi officers,
filled with Nazi uniforms.
The Nazis have moved
from the periphery
to the center of the movie.
And that's part of the terror
that the film dramatizes.
And it also therefore
of course dramatizes
the limits of satire,
because the cabaret itself,
like the characters, imagines
itself to be exempted
from or apart from history.
It can maintain its
mockery, its distance.
Satire can protect me.
And of course the
cabaret is just
as naive as the
characters themselves.
It's overwhelmed by the
forces of history in a way
that the characters
themselves also are.
Both of these films
in their own way
have generated a tremendously
interesting and serious volume
of discourse, both in terms
of their musical qualities
and the qualities of
their choreography,
and in terms of their content.
They're really
such complex films
that watching them
together makes
an immense intellectual
demand on everyone.
I know you're capable
of that, but I
hope that you'll
take the time to let
the implications of these films
settle into your mind for days,
and maybe even weeks
after you've watched them.
And I hope, of course, that
this first viewing will only
be the first of many.
I wish you the joy of
these wonderful movies.